التاريخ والاثار لم تستطع الصمود ضد زلزال
المدمر تعرضت قلاع تاريخيه ومبان اثريه في
تركيا وسوريا الى اضرار كبيره قلعه غازي
عنتاب التاريخيه تضررت بشده وفق ما ذكرت
رويترز ووسائل اعلام تركيا اما في سوريا
لم تسلم الاثار التاريخيه حيث لحقت اضرار
كبيره بقلعه حلب التاريخيه وبمبان اثريه
في حماه وغيرها نتابع
حسب وسائل اعلام تركيا فان قلعه غازي
عنتاب التاريخيه تعرضت لاضرار جسيمه بسبب
مركزها الذي عرضها بشده للزلزال في منطقه
بازارجيك في كهرمان مرعش تعرضت ايضا قلعه
حلب لاضرار منها سقوط اجزاء من الطاحونه
العثمانيه وحدوث تشققات وتصدع وسقوط
لاجزاء من الاسوار الدفاعيه الشماليه
الشرقيه كما سقطت اجزاء كبيره من قبه
مناره الجامع الايوبي وتعرضت واجهه التكيه
العثمانيه لاضرار ظهرت ايضا تصدعات
وتشققات على واجهه المتحف الوطني في حلب
في حلب الشهباء ايضا المدينه القديمه
تعرضت لانهيارات وتصدعات في الكثير من
المباني القديمه السكنيه وسقوط عدد من
ماذن الجوامع التاريخيه حماك ذلك طالتها
اضرار الزلزال في حي الباشوره التاريخي
حيث
واجهه احد العقارات القديمه الاثريه في
مدينه السلميه افادت التقارير عن سقوط
الجزء العلوي من ماذنه جامعه الامام
اسماعيل
وشهدت اجزاء متساقطه من الجدران الخارجيه
لقلعه
[موسيقى]
طبعا نشير بانه قلعه غازي عنتاب التركيه
يعني هذه القلعه مدرج على قائمه يونسكو
للمدن الابداعيه يعني قلعه تاريخيه
بامتياز نتحدث عن العديد من الاثار
التاريخيه التي للاسف دمرت ايضا بفعل
الزلزال ليس فقط في تركيا بل ايضا في
سوريا بالتالي نعود مره اخرى من حيث بدانا
في بدايه صباح العربيه وفي سياق هذه
التغطيه نذهب مره اخرى الى القامش لمراسل
صباح العربيه من هناك جمعه كاش جمعه اهلا
بك مره اخرى معنا نتحدث عن العديد من
المباني الاثريه التي تضررت وسويت بالارض
بشكل كامل بفعل الزلزال ما هو وضعها الان
خصوصا اذا ما بدانا بقلعه حلب
مرحبا نادين من جديد نعم مثل البشر ايضا
لم يسلم الحجر الحجر الذي يشكل في عدد من
المواقع
الحضاري والانساني بسوريا وتركيا وللعالم
اجمع يعني خاصه عندما نتحدث عن انقلاب
اهميه قلعه غازي عنتاب التاريخيه المعروفه
التي شكلت المعلمه السياحي الاكبر والذي
كان يزوره يعني عشرات الالاف من السواح من
مختلف دول العالم هذه القلعه مصنفه على
لائحه التراث العالمي لليونسكو ايضا على
نفس هذه اللائحه توجد قلعه حلب المعلمه
السياحي الابرز في مدينه حلب تعرض اجزاء
كبيره من هذه القلعه للانهيار خاصه في
البلدان الاول الذي ضرب يعني مناطق واسعه
من سوريا صباح يوم
امس يعني كان هناك يعني
صور وفيديوهات مؤثره وموجعه لعشاق هذه
القلعه التي تشكل رمزا لمدينه حلب والتي
غنى فيها ابرز فنانين المدينه وكانت يعني
حاضنه لابرز نتاجات الفنيه والثقافيه
لمدينه حلب المشاهد يعني مؤثره
وموجعه لسكان هذه المدينه اضافه الى اسواق
اخرى اسواق شعبيه واسواق تاريخيه معروفه
بان رائحه الهيل والبول والقهوه يعني
التركيه سواء في في تركيا او في سوريا
لعشاق لعشاق هاتين المدينتين يبدو ان حتى
الانساني والتراث الحضاري لسوريا مهدده في
هذا الزلزال يحتاج لك الى الجهود الدهود
كبيره من البلدين لاعاده ترميم ما تضرر في
هذا الزلزال
دقيقتان كانتا كفيلتين بمحو الاف السنين
فلم يسلم البشر وحتى الحجر شكرا لك من
القمشلي مراسل العربيه جمعه عكاش شكرا لك